the list of people who believe that
Donald Trump is not going to relinquish
control of the White House peacefully if
he loses the 2020 election is growing
and it includes at least one Republican
candidate now who happens to be running
against Donald Trump his name's William
weld he is a former governor here in
Massachusetts he previously was running
as a libertarian he now is a Republican
and he says that Donald Trump will not
leave voluntarily if he loses the 2020
election from Real Time with Bill Maher
Bill Maher asked if Trump loses do you
think he'll leave and William weld said
not voluntarily he'll have a run at
saying it was a rigged game so I'm not
leaving I don't think the military and
indeed even the Justice Department the
rank-and-file the investigative agencies
would stand for that in this country
I like that William weld added that last
piece because it's important for us on
the left and not that William weld is on
the left but for anyone on the left who
is even entertaining this idea of what
would Trump do would he try to hold on
to control if he lost the 2020 election
we are not like the crazy right
with the birther stuff and the Obama's
going to cancel the 2016 election stuff
which is why I think it's important to
point out that William weld is not
saying Trump would succeed at staying in
the White House even if he lost the 2020
election he might try to pull it or try
to delay it but ultimately the centers
of power in the country wouldn't allow
it and I also think that that's the most
likely scenario and every single time
that this comes up I go out of my way
not to be hyperbolic because with Obama
there was so much nonsense about Obama
won't leave Obama will cancel the 2016
election and declare himself indefinite
president or Obama will declare martial
law as a justification for remaining
president beyond his eight years we want
to be a sober and realistic as possible
about this with Barack Obama
there was no indication whatsoever that
Barack Obama had those sort of
anti-democratic authoritarian tendencies
with regard to the presidency in trying
to not relinquish power
there was nothing Obama said which
suggested that he might out of his own
concoction not accept the raziel
of an election so when the right said
Obama won't leave it was 110 percent BS
with Trump it's not a hundred and ten
percent BS it's still not likely that it
would happen though right Trump has all
the way back to 2016 in the debates said
maybe he would accept the election
results maybe he wouldn't if they showed
that he lost depending on what he thinks
about the election results Trump has
said president for life
like what China made possible recently
is interesting and maybe we would try it
sometime
Trump has said years ahead of the 2020
election two years ahead that the only
way Democrats can defeat him in 2020 is
via fraud that is yet another one of
these sort of pretexts to the idea that
he might not accept the election results
Trump has lied about the validity of
past elections remember he claimed three
to five million people voted illegally
in 2016 for Hillary Clinton and that in
reality if you account for those three
to five million alleged illegal votes he
won the popular vote as well as the
electoral vote Trump has made clear that
he has a degree of narcissism that might
make him unable emotionally to accept
defeat so when people talk about Trump
won't leave the White House peacefully
if he loses is it more likely that he
would try to retain power than would
someone like Barack Obama obviously the
answer is yes is it likely Trump would
succeed if he tried at not relinquishing
the White House I don't think it's very
likely so what we need to do is let's
just work on voting him out rather than
focusing on whether or not he would
leave let's work on preventing voter
suppression and manipulation tactics to
actually hand Donald Trump the victory
because much more likely than Trump
loses and somehow stays in the White
House is that the combination of voter
ID laws and election machine tampering
and foreign influence and reductions in
voting hours and closures of polling
places all together push Donald Trump
into victory that's what we need to most
proactively be working to prevent I
agree with William weld that if Trump
tries not to give up
roll of the white house that the forces
of power I know that the Justice
Department's in the tank forum I know
all of that stuff but I think that that
would even be too far I think that he
would ultimately be removed and there's
a really big problem in American culture
today American political culture today
that this relates to expectations
expectations aren't being managed
properly so take impeachment for example
which will talk about the expectation
shouldn't be can we remove Trump via
impeachment by the 2020 election because
that's not happening the expectation
should be can impeachment proceedings
expose the content of the Moller report
enough to damage Trump to make sure that
he loses the 2020 election we have to
manage our expectations and similarly if
Trump loses the 2020 election and tries
to stay in power could he actually do it
I believe William weld is right and the
answer is no that he would be removed
but he might try to argue that the
election was bogus that it was rigged
that it was fraudulent whatever because
he's done it before in an election he
won but who knows what he would do in an
election that he loses last thing on
this the idea that the reason Trump
would be so adamant about not losing has
been floated as maybe being the statute
of limitations on obstruction there's
this idea that Trump it's not so much
that he wants to be president for
another four years although his ego
would take a hit if he were to lose but
it's the idea that if he is not
president for another four years he
could end up indicted for obstruction
because the statute of limitations would
not have expired there is a way around
that which would be if Trump loses the
2020 election three days before the
inauguration of the next president Trump
resigns Mike Pence becomes president and
issues a pre-emptive pardon for Donald
Trump it might work it might not the
legal experts have sort of different
views on that but there is a path even
if Trump loses in 2020 to protecting
himself from indictment on obstruction
after he's gone
just something to keep in mind